mais d'abord cette info tv tours
l'entreprise pharmaceutique fareva à
amboise est à l'arrêt depuis mardi elle
serait victime d'une cyber-attaque des
données auraient été volés et une rançon
serait exigée pour qu'elle soit restitué
ce thread cas aussi d'autres sites du
groupe en france sur place on retrouve
florent clavel pour les dernières
informations une cyberattaque entouré
d'un halo de mystère ce que l'on sait à
cette heure c'est qu'une grande partie
de l'activité du site d'amboise derrière
moi et paralysé 350 des 500 salariés ne
travaillerait plus la cyber attaque
aurait eu lieu mardi vers 2 heures du
matin près de la totalité des systèmes
informatiques de l'entreprise serait
désormais inaccessible et limitant
grandement la production sur le site
au total quatre usines en france
auraient été touchées en seine-et-marne
dans l'eure à angers est chez nous donc
à amboise mais pas seulement
les hackers s'en serait pris aussi à
d'autres sites en italie et aux etats
unis
cette attaque est d'autant plus
troublante que l' usine d'amboise doit
conditionner un vaccin anti covit 19
allemand alors pourquoi cette attaque
s'agit-il d'un rançonnage un vol de
données contre de l'argent
on sait que ces informations sur les
vaccins valent aujourd'hui très cher
nous avons joint le service
communication du groupe fareva en
ardèche pour l'heure c'est silence radio
sujet sensible il faut dire que fareva
avec douze mille salariés et plus d'un
milliard 800 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires est un géant de la sous
traitance pharmaceutiques et cosmétiques